it's seven o'clock this is sky news
breakfast these are our top stories this
morning
freedom for care home residents as the
government announces they'll be able to
leave their homes for outdoor visits
without needing to self-isolate on
return
the first thing i would like to do
is to go and see my wife's grave
the department for transport misses a
deadline to publish its traffic lights
list for international travel but
reports suggest holidays will be given
the green light from the 17th of may
we'll be live at a vaccination center in
delhi
as india's daily coronavirus cases rise
by a record 400
000 as the clock takes down to polling
day we look at what's at stake in
scotland's parliamentary elections
and what it could mean for the uk
[Applause]
rave return 3 000 clubbers hit the dance
floor in liverpool
in a pilot event with no masks and no
social distancing
in sport premier league clubs players
and managers unite
behind a social media boycott to tackle
online abuse and discrimination
and as we leave the fourth driest april
on record will there be any wet weather
for the start of may
i'll have the details for you later in
the programme
and at quarter to eight we'll take a
look at the newspapers with athei adam
and thomas copeland
[Music]
good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast thank you for joining us
the government has announced that from
tuesday care home residents will be
allowed to leave their homes for
low-risk visits without having to
self-isolate
currently residents have to quarantine
for 14 days on return
but the health department is loosening
restrictions after a charity threatened
legal action
people will now be permitted to go for a
walk visit a loved one's garden and even
go for a meal
outside as molena vasilenovich reports
the new freedoms can't come
too soon for some residents
jim kelly hasn't left his care home in
months because rules meant that if he
went out
even just for a walk he would have had
to quarantine in his room for two weeks
afterwards
but from tuesday that regulation will be
scrapped
and jim already knows where he'll go
first
i would think the first thing i would
like to do
is to go and see my wife's grave
she passed away in september
and i felt like a prisoner ever since i
just like to go to the grave
and pay my respects
and then maybe go and have a meal with
the family
that would be a bonus
his daughter says the rule change means
her father can once again
feel like he's part of the family i
think the flexibility to be able to do
a little go for a coffee you know take a
flask of coffee and go for a little walk
or
if he's feeling down you can just you
know he can ring us and say
do you fancy a walk do you can i come
over for coffee in your garden because
luckily dad can still drive
the government says it can now drop the
quarantined rule because covet cases
continue to fall
it's one more step to getting back to
normal says care minister helen waitley
but outings must be limited to outdoor
spaces and private gardens
and residents can't meet in groups some
though feel that the quarantined rule
should have never been in place
the requirement for residents to
self-isolate for two weeks after a
single outing meant that really
most of them haven't been out of the
care home in months and that campaign to
say
didn't make any sense because care home
staff would still come in and out
every day without restrictions a rights
group says the regulation deprived
people in care of their agency and
autonomy
what this last year of the pandemic has
brutally exposed
is that there is a whole section of
society those people
old and young who live in care homes who
have been deprived of their liberties
who are treated
as if they are different and less than
the rest of
the than the rest of us and we just need
to keep an eye on that
for jim and many like him this newly
restored freedom means
life will have more joy once again
milena vaseline
sky news
the government will miss an initial
first of may deadline for publishing
grades of countries under a new traffic
light system for international travel
the department for transport now says
the list will be made public
in early may pressure is mounting from
the travel industry
to provide clarity well emma virtue
joins me now from
the newsroom uh emma what are the the
repercussions of this
missed deadline well i think mainly an
enormous amount of
uncertainty just 16 days to go until in
theory
people in england at least can head off
on holiday again but we know there'll be
this traffic light system
but we don't know what country will be
on which list
so green amber red now with all three
lists
you'll have to take a test before you
head back to the uk but if if it's a
country on the green list
and there aren't expected to be many of
those then you'll have to have a test
on day two but otherwise free to go
about your business
ambulance people will need to
self-isolate for 10 days and have two
tests on days two and eight and for
redless countries
uh people will have to quarantine as
they have been now
in a hotel so travelers
travel industry enormously up in the air
lacking in clarity and in fact jet 2
made a decision that they wouldn't
operate any holidays or flights until
the end of june
because of that uncertainty there is
some good news though so there are no
guarantees that may the 17th
would be the date it was part of the
government's roadmap but things are
looking good there were four tests that
had to be made
met so was the vaccination program on
track yes
low infection rates low death rates and
also low risk from
variance of concern things all looking
positive there so hopefully travel will
go ahead
but what's needed now are some answers
so people can make plans
emma thank you let's take a look now the
latest
covid figures in the most recent 24-hour
period 2 381 new cases of coronavirus
were reported
another 15 people have died which means
the total number of deaths is now 127
517. another 122 039 people have
received their first vaccination
while 488 9114
got their second meaning 48.7 million
jabs have now been given out across the
uk
that's 65 of the population
well the crisis in india continues to
escalate it's been another record day
with almost
402 000 new cases that takes the total
number of covid 19 cases there to more
than 19.1 million
with 211 853
deaths experts argue the real totals
could be far
greater from today india will attempt to
step up
its faltering vaccination drive by
calling for adults 18 and older
to get a jab our special correspondent
alex crawford is in
delhi for us this morning at the
vaccination center i believe
uh all steam ahead with the vaccination
program it seems alice
i'm afraid it's very bad news for anyone
who wants to try and get a vaccination
in delhi or indeed throughout the
country it is not going well
at all most hospitals in the indian
capital do not have
enough stocks of vaccines and are having
to delay
the actual rollout today they were
trying to extend it and had
said that they wanted to have 18 years
and older
to come and get vaccinated as a way of
trying to
stop this huge spike in the number of
cases they have set
global record highs in the number of
coronavares cases
for the last 10 days and another record
again today but most of the hospitals
not just in delhi but throughout the
country have said they don't have the
stocks
they're trying to put people off they're
trying to tell people don't come and
queue up
this is one of the rare vaccination
centers which has got
a small stop they've asked people to
book appointments on the app it's a
fraction
an absolutely tiny fraction they will
only be able to give
about 600
1200 vaccinations today in a city itself
which is made up of 17 million people
now a lot of people are asking how why
has a country which is the world's
biggest manufacturing vaccines
not have enough stock to vaccinate its
entire population
it has been shipping out since january
66 million doses to countries something
like
60 countries around the world on the day
that it hit
global record highs in corona rise cases
was april the 22nd that was the day that
it shipped out
even more to paraguay it's managed to
ship
out to bhutan for instance which has
totally vaccinated 93 of its population
within 16 days
and yet this country has not got its own
a lot of
a lot of the residents and the citizens
of india are asking
how has this happened was there too much
of a drive
to perhaps make money on the vaccines
and not
inoculate its own citizens the
scientists
have been saying they warned about this
several months back
and right now the people of india have
been told they might have to wait
another
three weeks to get inoculated that's
less than
at the moment less than two percent of
the population here
are fully inoculated so a pretty dire
more grim news from india
uh so alex no uh suggestion as to when
they might be able to
continue the vaccination program um
normally when they will have
the stock it i mean it's a real race
against time because
in trying to there's no way even with
everyone shutting their borders now the
americans are
cutting off flights within the next few
days uh
a number of other countries are
considering cutting off flights
that is not going to work for india they
need to inoculate
their citizens and they're talking about
maybe 10
15 days time where right now
they are still so overwhelmed with the
number of people
sick and dying in their hospitals their
hospitals still
cannot cope they're still putting out
sos distress called
desperately asking for oxygen because
they cannot cope with the number of
people
who need it there are no hospital beds
there's
no medicines there's no remedial one of
the key
medicines that's been used to try and
combat the effects of
coronavirus it's a terribly grim
situation
and today yet another knock-on effect of
not having enough vaccines it's really
not going at all
well for india and we saw the prime
minister narendra modi
he put out on his twitter feed a couple
of hours ago
turning up to a sikh temple to pray many
commentators and analysts are viewing
that as an attempt to try and
switch attention away from a terribly
terribly grim
situation inside the country towards
other other issues and and focus much
more on
on on him praying rather than what he's
doing
to try and correct all of this
mismanagement and try and turn the
situation around
alex uh thank you hope to be back to you
later on in
the morning thank you
time now for a look at the morning's
other main stories and
game of thrones actress esme bianco has
sued the singer marilyn manson
alleging sexual assault and battery the
lawsuit claims he coerced the british
actress with drugs
force and threats of force more than a
dozen other women have made
similar allegations against the singer
who has since been dropped by his record
label
the artist rejects all allegations of
abuse against him calling them horrible
distortions of reality
a campaign is being launched to create a
memorial inside saint paul's cathedral
for those who've died from covid19
it's hoped the memorial would provide a
reflective space for visitors and
families
to remember loved ones who will be open
and it will be open to those of all
faiths
disneyland in california has reopened
for the first time in more than a year
as it was revealed more than 100 million
americans have been fully vaccinated
against kobit 19.
disney fans who visited cheered and
screamed through face mask
as the park reopened to 25 capacity
we're just excited to see the cast
members back at work
excited to see things up and running
again we missed it we missed it a lot
i was coming two or three times a week
maybe up five times a week
so not being able to come to the park
was really rough it was hard this is my
happy place i mean
disney is great so yeah we're excited to
be at disneyland
returning now to our top story and care
home residents will be able to leave
their homes for outdoor visits without
needing to self-isolate on return
from tuesday they can spend time outside
sit in private gardens and see friends
and family
in a socially distanced fashion joining
me now is the chair of the independent
care group mike
padgeam good morning to you um what do
you
understand this to mean in practical
terms
how will it work as far as you know well
i think it's a victory for common sense
i'm very pleased to see it happening
um so that the residents can enjoy um
some of the freedoms that the rest of us
can now has locked down eases so
i think it will work well i'd like to
see it go further in due course
but we have to take each step cautiously
don't we so um it's it's it's good news
and i congratulate jon's campaign for
the work they've done
to bring pressure on government to make
this happen quicker than it would have
happened otherwise
what changes will it mean for staff
though that the management of it and the
executing of it
well i think i i would like a little bit
more notice from governor because i i
think that we've got to make sure that
we've uh
got enough staff who will accompany
the clients and residents when they go
out but also the designated visitors
um if there isn't that member staff to
go with them they should be ready
available
what the challenge of course is putting
those all those arrangements into place
quickly enough because tuesday's not far
away but we're really pleased that we
can do it
so um i i thank the government for it
and john's campaigns as i said earlier
and what type of preparations will you
have to put in place now as you say that
there hasn't been much
notice to be ready on time no well i
think i just asked
the public and residency cams have been
very very patient i would just ask them
for a little bit more patience whilst we
put plans into action because
um we obviously can't take everyone out
in one go we've got to do it and stage
it by appointment probably
just ask people to bear with us um so
that we can put
all those arrangements into place so um
yes
it won't be easy but i'm really pleased
we can do it and hopefully with some
some some good weather coming up um
residents would enjoy the freedom the
same as the rest of the country because
they do deserve it somewhat some people
have not been outside for whatever year
so
it's great news i would like to see it
go further as soon as it's safe to do so
as well
and how how would you like to see it go
further in what way
what i'd like to be able to see if
people have had the vaccination i'd like
to be able to see people
actually um you know be able to go to
inside
their relatives homes if necessary
that's a little bit further down the
line of course
we've got to make sure that um there's
trust there at the moment that everyone
abides by the rules
um when people do go out because there's
a lot of trust got to be put in place by
people to make sure that you know that
they're not mixing indoors and not
mixing with lots of other people
but it is a step in the right direction
we just got to keep the pressure on to
make sure
that as the rest of the country unlocks
that resident care homes can have as
much freedom as everyone else
whilst of course protecting because it's
been a very difficult time
for care homes over the last 12 months
and how will you decide which
residents are eligible to to to go
outside
venture outside for visits i mean that
presumably they'll be
queuing up to to be the first in line
but not everyone
can can use this facility in the first
instance no i think uh you know without
getting too
boring about things that each client
will have a risk assessment to
to show what's best for them but yes
you're quite right there will probably
be a queue of people that's why i would
have liked a little bit more notice but
will heyo
cast off have been done a fantastic job
we will do the best we can in the short
space of time we've got
how's it going to be well i guess first
come first served
we want to make sure those people whose
mental health perhaps
will do with an an extra booth boost
perhaps
will be first in line but it's going to
be very difficult um
to choose and to make sure everyone's
happy but we'll do everyone give
everyone a fair crack at the whip
and do as much as we possibly can but as
i said earlier we just asked for a
little bit more patience why put those
plans into police
uh you've mentioned a couple of times
that that it seems to have been sort of
a last-minute thought
by the government and you would have
liked more
guidance what would have informed you
further to allow you to
to plan and to have all the right
systems in place well perhaps if we'd
had a week it's always difficult and i
only found out myself late yesterday
evening i remember
easter bank holiday we got notice about
visitors and care homes so
it always seems to come out late one
evening on a bank holiday when perhaps
staffing is not at this highest i would
have liked uh
perhaps a week's notice so we could put
the schedules in place and give people
what they need quickly but um we are
where we are we will make the best
of it and give people the freedom they
need i was just pointing out that
actually the government
you know needs to think sometimes when
it makes these announcements to give us
a bit more notice
mike pearson thanks very much love your
optimism uh good luck
for tuesday thank you
let's take a look at the weather for you
now with the naz
and should we be optimistic about the
weather um
yes yes actually gardeners should be
optimistic
because there's finally some significant
rain coming for this bank holiday
weekend
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning so we leave behind the
fourth driest april on record although
it was a rather wet end to it with lots
of april showers and we start off for
the beginning of may with
showers around as well for the end of
the bank holiday weekend there will be
some significant rainfall
but to begin with this morning lots of
sunshine largely dry much like previous
morning it's a chilly start with a frost
in places there are some coastal showers
some showers over central and
southwestern parts of scotland too
then into this afternoon cloud bubbles
up and the showers become more frequent
it will be slow moving as the winds are
light in some spots there could be heavy
and thundery with the risk of hail
some wintry over the high ground with
north and it's disappointingly cool for
the time of year
tonight the showers fade away chilly and
frosty again sunshine and showers again
tomorrow
wet and windy on bank holiday monday
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now if you've ever wondered who holds
the world record for the longest
golf drive to ever land in a moving car
as i have
often here is your answer
money money fall
it's golf professional marcus armitage
who's broken a nine-year-old record by
driving the ball 303 yards at elvington
airfield in yorkshire
the ball landed in a convertible car
driven by paul o'neill that was
traveling at more than 70 miles per hour
it wasn't the duo's first attempt
previous efforts had resulted in a
smashed windshield
so when they finally did it you can
understand why they celebrated
so wildly
uh the big question is why jackie
i don't know julian why are you asking
me i've tried to watch things like top
gear before i don't get it
do you think it's a boy thing um
possibly
possibly hooray for those golfers i'm so
glad that
i'm impressed oh yeah and off the field
rivalries are put aside as football
unites behind a social media boycott to
tackle online hate and discrimination
this weekend
blast wire coin task proposal left a
furious
derek azura threatening to abandon
tonight's heavyweight fight against
joseph parker
and it's lights out in neil as the
england women's rugby team secure
victory over france
in the strangest of circumstances
[Music]
[Music]
they say they can't go back to myanmar
yet if they do
they say they'll be killed
[Applause]
[Music]
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
if there is a bigger explosion this area
would be in the danger zone
these traffic jams snake for hours up
and down this hillside it means pressure
day
can't access those and knees
[Music]
you can see the depth of water if you
have a look in front of us
there are people wading through it
[Music]
i think experiencing the two million
person march in hong kong
that was a moment i don't like the
chinese government it's true
[Music]
it was real people power in action
police have been foreign
[Music]
here and just one of them is the size of
around 31 000
football pitches siobhan robbins
sky news bangkok
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers welcome to
divided states
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news
entertainment podcast for wherever you
are welcome to the safety rage on sunday
podcast
for the ones who want to know more
welcome to the all that politics podcast
for the listeners from sky news
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free jackie is back with us to take
us through all of the sport
i thought you were going to tell them
what we were talking about in the break
it was the wee donkey
but he has not made it into my bulletin
let me tell you now
you'll have to explain that another time
i i don't think i do have to explain it
lights out across social media this
weekend for footballers and
actual lights out in the women's rugby
let's have a look
this sports bulletin is brought to you
by vitality committed to getting 100
million people 20
more active by 2025
well the best place it feels like to
start is the spurs game
and your performance and the result in
general how much did the club need that
to get the revenge from the
first game that we had against them
because we still had the inside
everyone had the inside you know losing
like that at home
and um just for the point as well with
the result
that happened in the weekend that was
good for us
it was very important there was a really
nice moment after the game that the
cameras picked up you and ollie having a
little chat
it looked like he was complimenting you
on a part of your game what's your
relationship like with all at the moment
well he wasn't complimenting me he was
he was telling me that i should have
scored
but but now obviously uh
we have a very good relation um
he understand me uh he put me on the
pitch he trust me
to uh to play in the middle on the left
and
uh that's all that's all the player
needs
there was a really interesting what we'd
call like a war of words between oligar
soldier and jose mourinho
before the game and after the game and
it was amusing for us to watch what did
you guys make of it as players
i don't know what happened i'm sure
mourinho put something or said something
that would the people speak that's what
he does
and uh yeah we got the result that we
wanted
just uh ollie knows it and
we enjoyed that we enjoyed that moment
what do you think the differences are
between
jose mourinho's style of management and
oligarch social style of management
what i have now with the with the oli
is different because he would
he wouldn't go against the players maybe
he doesn't put them
uh it's not like you put them on the
side and they don't
they don't exist anymore and i think
that's the difference between
mourinho and ollie
because once uh i had a great
relationship with the
with mourinho everybody see that and
the next day you don't know what
happened and that's the change
the strange thing that uh that i had
with mourinho
and i cannot explain to you because even
me i don't know
tell us about the role that you play
because when you were bought by
manchester united it was a
very boxer box midfielder kind of role
you've changed so much and at the
weekend we saw you play far
right in the front three what do you
prefer
i like to do obviously attacking i like
to be in the box i like to be this easy
for my team
if i can do both i will do it i like to
defend as well
to recoverable and get to the box i just
like to be free
and play my football for you to perform
at your best do you feel that
you need a consistent role or are you
happy to float around and do whatever it
is that ollie wants you to do
i think for every player you know you
always feel com
you need to play when you feel
comfortable when you're doing
well there and you carry on you keep
doing it um
i think it will be harder it will be
more difficult for someone to be
consistent
and play well when you change a lot the
manager tell me to be deeper i will be
deeper i will give my best there
and if i have to be a bit happier in the
pocket
i will be i will do the same and be
there try to be in fluent as well
help the team do much as i can
i'm in i'm in we're all in to kick it
out
partnering to end racism in sport
brian swanson and calvary solokul on set
with me to discuss
if the super league is indeed dead and
if not what's going to happen
next and we'll have more on the
discussion about whether fans ownership
is a model for the future of english
football but next we're going to hear
from the england captain harry kane who
has praised fans
for protesting against the super league
supporters turned up outside the
tottenham hotspur stadium
before the game in the premier league
against southampton on wednesday to
voice
their objections to the proposals as
well as
chairman daniel levy and owners enoch
i'm surprised i'll be totally honest
committed to getting 100 million people
20
more active by 2025
you're watching scania's breakfast
coming up with the local elections
looming we head to scotland to see
what's at stake when the country goes to
the polls
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back liverpool has become the
first city to host a near normal concert
in the uk with 3 000 people attending a
rave
with no social distancing or masks it's
part of a pilot scheme to test how safe
a return to live events would be
katarina vertotsi watched on in
liverpool a report
warning that her report does contain
flashing images from the start
welcome back
this is the first uk club event since
the pandemic began
it's loud it's
busy and for some
after a year with nothing like this it's
really quite emotional
my best friend started crying before she
came and it does feel a bit emotional it
feels a bit surreal
it feels dead weird to be back around so
many people
i like without mass without saucy
distance and stuff
honestly it feels amazing i've just been
in the middle of the crowd now it just
felt like an actual club again like i
just loved it
it was great honestly
3 000 people have bought a ticket for
today's
event and each one of them have had to
have a negative october 19 test result
within the past 24 hours but once
they've got that and they're inside
it's clubbing as it always has been no
mask
no social distancing and even if you're
someone that's not been clubbing in
years
it still feels pretty special
[Music]
but this isn't just a party it's a petri
dish
part of government trials to see if and
how things like nightclubs can reopen
safely as lockdown eases we're asking
people to take
another test at home for research
purposes on the day of the event and
five days afterwards we're asking them
questions
we're measuring the air are there any
pockets of stale air measuring carbon
dioxide levels
what is the safety blueprint the public
health safety net that we can build
around these events
to open them and keep them open
of course this isn't just about finding
ways to give people a good time
it's about restarting an events industry
that stopped
overnight more than 12 months ago i'm
not an emotional person and
and i i certainly had a few teary eyes
today it's just been
it's been very special and i'm just
seeing the reaction of people
they're actually my staff the reaction
on social media from industry colleagues
it has been absolutely amazing to see
they call this event
the first dance they hope it'll be the
first
of many catherine of the topsy sky news
in liverpool
when scottish voters go to the polls on
thursday the outcome could have
significant consequences for the uk
a total of 129 msps will be elected to
hollywood
depending on the results boris johnson
could come under more pressure
to grant a second independence
referendum scotland's former first
minister alex salmon is standing as a
candidate for his new party alba
in the north east of scotland from where
james matthews reports
over the cliff edge in the aberdeenshire
village of penan
they made the film local hero an 80s
classic
in which a stubborn man of pensionable
age upsets many around him
by refusing to quietly disappear in this
election
fiction meets fact starring alex salmond
local hero or anti-hero i headed for the
red telephone box
the one made iconic by the movie
i made a call to professor james
mitchell what lies ahead
for the local candidate it certainly
will be around the margins if there was
to be a referendum and there was to be a
representation in the polling then that
will undermine
the leadership of the u.s cause that the
snp would want
much of scotland sees this election
through the prism of the constitution
arguments for and against independence
we gauge the view on what else matters
to people here
the answer is a lot even if the light
and shade of the independence debate
is front and center
these are fish fingers just one of the
products exported worldwide
by thistle seafoods a major employer in
peterhead
for whom the disruption of brexit has
shaped the view on
independence if there's going to be
scottish independence we know that
there's going to be a hard border in
scotland now between
scotland and the rest of uk and i think
for us
certainly thistle seafoods i couldn't
see us maintaining manufacturing
presence in scotland on the back of that
around aberdeen harbour supply vessels
speak to the size and significance
of the oil and gas industry one that
awaits a first election
since the scottish government declared a
climate emergency
as we head towards net zero there will
still be demand for oil and gas
and so our argument is that we need to
be optimizing the indigenous
industry that we have the jobs the
skills and the experience
and that we shouldn't seek to shut that
down prematurely
and what of the generation that's only
known an snp
government in scotland voting for the
first time
we drop by the dojo i want to see a safe
a safe approach to coming out of
lockdown
and i'm hoping that we'll continue to
work towards the climate change
from the pandemic obviously and
recovery from brexit as well as well
as the climate change and
opportunities for young people no one
doubts nicola sturgeon will win this
election
the question is by how much many believe
the winning margin will be the measure
of the case for indirect ii
there is more to this election than the
constitution
but for the independence debate what
happens next
hinges on what happens next week james
matthews sky news in penan
aberdeen
looks beautiful there doesn't it what's
the weather going to do to us here
his nest
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
very good morning to you it's a case of
sunshine and showers once again for
today so after we've just left
april the fourth driest on record but
a wet end to it we continue with the wet
theme for the start
of may and in fact it's going to turn
very wet by the end of the bank holiday
weekend
this morning though starts to find much
like yesterday morning
we are going to see lots of sunshine out
there this morning it's a chilly start
of course from the close guys overnight
and there is apache frost in places and
there are some
showers dotted about mainly around
coastal counties and around central and
southwestern parts of scotland
then as we go into this afternoon cloud
amounts will increase and with that
showers will become more widespread
and winds are light again so those
showers could be quite slow moving maybe
even heavy and thundery in places
with the risk of hail maybe even wintry
across the high ground or the north and
temperatures disappointing for the time
of year
a little below average although degrees
are so high than they were yesterday
uh tonight the showers will fade away
returning again once again for tomorrow
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
you're watching scania's breakfast still
to come we'll be taking a look at what's
making the front pages of the newspapers
with the author and broadcaster anthony
odom and the editor
of challenges northern ireland thomas
copeland please stay with us
we lost our son in 2016 not
long after he was born he was three days
old and we then
went on to um face secondary infertility
and uh and losses and ivf treatment
along the way
facing infertility for anyone is
incredibly difficult but i've
i felt that fertility struggles
after the death of a child just felt
impossibly cruel
and um yeah it went on for quite a few
years and it was um
quite a tough thing to go through
firstly it's hugely cathartic for me
writing over the past
almost five years since our son teddy
died has been a massive therapy for me
but when i started writing after he died
it was it was really a case of looking
for other women looking for other
parents who had been through
similar and once i started connecting
with other people i realized that
there's such a power in community
and actually to continue these
conversations and raise
our own voices that help to raise other
people's voices just
enables everyone to feel more
comfortable when we're talking about
loss or fertility struggles or you know
ivf
treatment it just really helps to sort
of continue that momentum
i mean i believe that online there is a
huge community of
women and men talking about their
experiences in
of going through fertility treatment and
you know statistics show that
one in six couples in the uk will
struggle to fall pregnant naturally
without some kind of assisted fertility
meaning that two percent of babies born
every year in
the uk are born through
assisted fertility and ivf and that's a
huge amount
of people that's like 20 000 babies born
every year and
it's a conversation i think we could all
be better at having um
because even if we aren't going through
it ourselves you know we might
know somebody who we work with or
somebody who lives on the same street as
us and it
it's really nice to be able to know the
right thing to say
to sort of support somebody if they do
choose to tell you what they're going
through
i'm tom chescher and i'm skye's asia
correspondent based here in beijing his
police officer was shot through the car
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
hello my name is ina braverman and i'm
the founder and ceo of eco-wade power
i believe that wave power which can
produce
twice the amount of electricity that the
world produces now
is definitely a great cause
[Music]
did you know pollen levels tend to be
higher in the morning
and at night the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
today there will be some bright or sunny
spells but also fairly widespread
showers
some of them will be heavy with hail and
thunder and even wintry over the high
ground
of the north so let's take a look at the
pollen forecast for today
moderate levels are expected pretty much
everywhere currently tree pollen is in
peak season with birch and ash airborne
in any sunny spells
and spores will increase temporarily
after any showers today too
the pollen reports sponsored by philips
connected air purifiers
back with us now to take us through the
newspapers author and broadcaster after
your dom
and the editor of challenges northern
ireland thomas copeland welcome back to
both of you
let's start with the eye first of all
affia and this story
uh barclays is predicting the biggest
economic boom
in 70 years
yes that's right so barclays are
predicting that the economy
is going to grow by 6.5
this year which would be the strongest
growth in the british economy since
1948 and of course i'm sure that's going
to draw some
post-war comparisons there and we've
heard a lot about what people are
calling revenge
spending so people having saved up money
over the lockdown period
and are now going out to spend that
money whether it's
on uh consumer items electricals you
know
luxury goods or if they've saved enough
perhaps to get on the property
ladder but now we have to realize that
there is a flip side to this
you know although some people have
managed to build up their savings during
lockdown
there are lots of people uh who burned
through their favors perhaps if they
lost their job
if they were furloughed now the farlow
scheme and and the uplifting universal
credit is ending in september
and so there will be a lot of people who
are going to be struggling
after this period of time and of course
there's going to be a lot of businesses
that are potentially going to go bust
and aren't going to be viable
anymore and the red flag alert showed
that
723 000 businesses are now in
significant financial distress
that's up 15 from the first from the
fourth quarter excuse me
in 2020 um so yes although
we are going to see this boom in the
economy i think we do have to realize
that on the other side a lot of people
who are struggling and who are going to
continue to struggle
and lots of those people tend to be from
demographics like from ethnic minorities
that potentially live in poorer areas of
the country as well
so whilst we are expecting bumper growth
of over six percent
we do have to have some plans in place
look after those people who may
potentially
fall through the crack indeed thomas
take us to the
times and to politics the local
elections uh
afoot and this article uh suggesting
that that labor might not do
as well as they hope to
yeah nothing particularly new there the
times of a double page spread here
looking at ahead the the to the may the
sixth elections uh principally council
elections but also
a few a variety of other merrell and
by-elections in there as well this
article is all about the red wall there
it says red wool
red wall blues um there's a lot of great
stats in here
very quick quick summary i won't bore
you it says laborers to lose dozens of
its council seats uh tourists to
increase their red wall seats by up to a
third
and also uh labor strategists suggesting
that they will lose hartley pools so
that's that by-election is taking place
a a real brexit supporting seat but a
labour seat since
its creation and that going to the
tories what 11 years
into tory uh premiership in 10 downing
street will be a really significant
moment
as a matter of fact you know in the
entirety of british parliamentary
history
not to mention now question is why one
of the stats that you read in this
article is that 54
of the red wall um constituents who were
surveyed by the times say that
labor just doesn't understand them what
does that tell us well it tells us
the cure stormer has failed to improve
the alienation that was so clear between
um those red wall labour heartland seats
and the labour party under jeremy corbyn
now of course that alienation had been
building for a long time it wasn't just
under jeremy corbyn but kirsten
was really elected as that kind of
figure who would try to improve
those kind of relationships reclaim
these seats and it's clear from the
polling that we're seeing
that isn't happening i mean if you look
back at
the at you know the general election
2019 there were two big things
that everybody pretty much agreed was
the reason that so many of those
northern seats went blue
one was corbin and the other was brexit
kirst armour of course was that kind of
icon for a second referendum
um and according to labour strategist
quoted in this piece
um his association with brexit is so
strong that it's becoming difficult to
overcome that in some of those seats let
me give me a quote
from the article one red walt tory so a
conservative in one of these seats says
quote
there's concern among colleagues that if
we win hartley pool so if the
conservatives win hardly poo
starmer might quit and that would be a
shame for us so that's from the
conservatives that tells you
you know the strength of feeling that is
clearly on display here
and the confidence that the tories have
that undercare stormer
their fortunes aren't going to improve
drastically in the north
um indeed uh to the mirror
i've only got the front page here but um
i think that this story
is suggesting and reporting that that
britney spears
has dementia has been diagnosed with
dementia is that right
well yes so this is um a story that's
arisen
from a bbc documentary which is coming
out at the beginning
of next week it seems like you asked for
one
britney spears documentary and four came
along
at one and this is all about britney
spears her father
and her conservatorship which has long
been discussed um so this bbc
documentary is on the iplayer at the
moment
and it's out next week and it's called
the battle for brittany
fans cash in a conservatorship and it
is saying in this documentary that one
of the reasons why britney spears father
requested this conservatorship
is that she has dementia apparently
there was some paperwork
that had to be filled in and one of the
tick boxes he picked
um was relating to her and said that she
had dementia placement
or treatment and it's thought that that
perhaps is the reason
why she's under conservative
conservatorship from her father and that
of course simply means that her father
has um control of her finances and
during this time she's been under this
conservative ship she's released four
albums
and gone on four global tours so of
course she has earned
quite a lot of money in that time now
she is going to speak about her
conservatorship in court for the first
time
she doesn't talk about it and so she's
going to be in court on the 23rd of june
to contest it saying that she wants her
lawyer to continue the conservatorship
if she has to have it if she cannot have
control of her own finances
uh but this has long been discussed you
know the free britney campaign
um are always you know gunning for her
always to have her back
saying that in some ways she's being
controlled by her father
potentially her mother as well and a
battle to keep
her finances under control and perhaps
reap the rewards of all the hard work
that she's doing
so yes this this documentary is on
wednesday
uh bbc two and nine pm um
britney spears and her conservatorship a
long discuss topic certainly
thomas many people's attentions are
turning to
some holidays possibility of whether
we'll be able to to travel
the express saying that the prime
minister will unveil the
green list of countries next week
finally
that's right the express is very excited
this morning with this here we go they
say boris drew a deal uh holiday list
the government looks set to announce
this sort of green list approved
countries for holidaying
i could have had two reactions to this
my initial reaction to the story was
fairly negative i was instantly thinking
you know the coveted waves that we're
seeing in france in germany across
europe
not to mention further afield places
like india you know and importing any of
the variants
that are on display across the world in
the uk could be a really critical way to
undermine our vaccine rule out and can
you imagine
if we we had a large spread of a variant
in the uk that was somehow
even sort of 10 more immune to the
vaccines
than the current covid cases that we
have in the uk that will be detrimental
and i don't think anybody wants to see
us go back over the last
number of months and try to re-vaccinate
huge
sways of the population but then you
know those
and those risks definitely still remain
but the other way of looking at it is of
course that
over the course of this lockdown i mean
i'm in northern ireland i'm very lucky
we have a very low population density
at some lovely countryside very nearby
to sort of any of the major metropolitan
areas but in huge parts of the uk
you know in cities you've got families
and flats you've been packed in there
for months at a time
they've been homeschooling their
children they've perhaps got multiple
generations all in the same house
it is entirely reasonable that we say to
to
to people in those kind of situations
let's try to release some of that
attention let's try to figure out ways
that we can get you away get you out on
holiday
at least of all because that's fantastic
for the tourism industry
and you know airlines are on their knees
not that i have a huge amount of
sympathy for airlines at the best of
times
still you know i i think a lot of people
might read this and say oh
i'm just unsure a bit too early perhaps
there's a middle ground here maybe a few
staycations across the uk support some
of the dying businesses in our seaside
business
suggested yes uh after take us into this
story in the independent um
it's the online version of the the story
and
quite distressing about a police officer
suspended over allegations of
hitting a disabled girl 30 times it says
with a battle
yes very distressing story actually so
this is a young girl 17 years old
and a vulnerable girl who's disabled she
was on a group walk and she
became distressed um so she came in
contact with police officers
got into a police car she flagged it
down got into the police car
and then got out and and then this is
when the altercation occurred
when the police officer hit her more
than 30 times
with the baton and also tasered her as
well
and as i said this is a young girl who
was disabled
who was vulnerable and the police
officers took no time
um to communicate with her who said
there was a complete lack of
communication
a breakdown in communication
and instead unreasonable force with you
yeah officer suspended uh
um over those allegations and that
obviously will be investigated affair
and thomas thank you very much for
taking us through the papers this hour
we shall see you in about 60 minutes
time